now just as many other countries are at
the moment Germany is taking an economic
hit due to a vastly increased energy
bills caused by Russia's invasion of
Ukraine Germany in particular has relied
on Russian gas but relations with
another autocratic regime have also come
under scrutiny China has become
Germany's biggest trading partner in
recent years but beijing's increasingly
assertive behavior is being watched with
concern in Berlin here's Germany's
economic affairs minister and Deputy
Chancellor Robert speaking after meeting
fellow G7 officials on Thursday
China is over and I can also say that
for the German government the times were
over when it was said trade no matter
what the humanitarian standards may be
we should no longer allow that this
means that we will show a more robust
trade stance through Europe towards
China
speaking there now let's bring Eric
bradberg he's a senior vice president in
the Europe practice of the Albright
Stonebridge group and the non-resident
senior fellow at the Atlantic Council
welcome to the day Mr Brad pack it seems
that this recognition has been a long
time coming wasn't this policy of hoping
to change China through trade always a
bit of a fallacy
perhaps although I do think historically
it made sense to engage China trying to
get China to become a responsible
stakeholder trying to play by the rules
in the International System but I think
it should have been clear way earlier
that that wasn't the decision that
Beijing made that China instead has
become more authoritarian and has
frankly engaged in practices that are
not fair such as you know stealing
intellectual property engaging and
buying up strategic assets to siphon off
Technologies but also bullying countries
like they've done recently with
Lithuania for instance I think it should
have been a wake-up call much earlier
but I do think that wake-up call is now
coming very very loud and very clear so
it is coming now but what's different
now is this just a Fallout from Russia's
war in Ukraine is it increased Chinese
assertiveness let's call it that if
we're looking at Taiwan or the
disruption caused by the covid-19
pandemic
yeah I think it is a sense I think that
we are less naive anymore as Europeans
and I think certainly Russia's war in
Ukraine contributes to that I mean I
think if anything it has underscored our
dependence on that authoritarian country
in terms of energy and I think that also
has served as a reminder of our
dependence on in a range of areas
including technology and raw materials
on another authoritarian country like
China
um but we I think we also learned that
during covid when so much we learned
about our Medical Supply chains were
dependent on China and China's
willingness to engage in this kind of
mask and vaccine diplomacy that we saw
oftentimes spreading this information in
Europe about the virus or about vaccines
so what I think we are seeing now is a
willingness to begin to put values in in
front of business and I think both
governments and companies are beginning
to learn this and it will be very
interesting to see especially in Germany
as Germany conducts its new National
Security strategy and its New China
strategy what will come out of that and
if that will be a change in attitude
towards China they will also lead to
businesses beginning to take different
decisions about investing and trading
with China
we're coming to a particular business in
a moment but first I would like to ask
you that Germany is facing a double hit
here losing cheap energy from Russia at
the same time as it's saying uh it's
going to wean itself off a major trading
Pond will Washington accept that that
will take a lot of time
well I think the United States has
certainly encouraged and pushed Germany
for a number of years to reduce its
dependence on Russian energy and we've
certainly seen in recent years certainly
during the Trump Administration strong
criticism of the north stream 2 pipeline
although the Biden administration of
course tried to compromise on that issue
in order to rebuild relations to Germany
I think Washington is confident that
Germany is taking this energy crisis
very seriously and is taking very real
steps to reduce that dependence on on
Russian oil and Russian gas and I think
in many ways the U.S has also been
supportive of those measures you know
promoting LNG exports to Europe helping
to broker uh trade agreements or or help
Europe import energy from from the
global markets because I think there's a
concern in Washington that this energy
crisis should it get really severe this
winter could also have political
ramifications could lead to maybe
Europeans being less willing to continue
to support the efforts to to assist you
Iranians but at the same time I also
think there's a little bit of a concern
in the U.S that by cutting off
dependence on Russia too quickly that
could actually drive up the energy
prices in ways that could lead to higher
gas prices in the US which could make
the Democrats vulnerable in the upcoming
midterms and I think that's why you saw
especially the United States and the G7
come out with this oil price cap idea
instead as a way to limit Russia's oil
revenues while still making sure that
the prices don't go up I want to come
back to single companies that you
mentioned earlier German car maker opal
today announced it is putting its plans
to expand its business into China on
whole is this change already a sign of
business feeling the Wind of Change
I do think we hear from businesses and
it by the way it's not completely new we
heard all the way back in 2019 from BDI
the the German uh industry Association
calling China systemic competitors it's
something that businesses have been
aware of but I think now we're seeing
companies actually take steps to reduce
and diversify
um their dependence on on China looking
at other potential players both in the
region and elsewhere around the world
um to to have manufacturing and to have
Supply chains but you are seeing some
companies and China is still a very big
Market
um you know you're seeing companies
continuing to invest in China but I
think they're mainly doing so because
they want to localize production for the
Chinese market in China kind of ring
fence China uh and their business there
and then diversify to other markets I
think the big change is really also
coming from government where I think in
in the past you saw certainly during
Chancellor anger Merkel the German
government very much encouraging
companies to go to China to trade more
with China now you're seeing and we
heard that from the remarks from from
Minister habit you're seeing uh the
government saying you know encouraging
companies to diversify and saying that
they may not get the type of financial
support from the government for their
businesses in China that they have been
used to getting so that is a shift not
only from companies but also from the
government
now uh Germany of course being one of
the if not the leading um economy in
Europe are you seeing evidence of
Germany taking on a more assertive
leadership role as the chancellor and
other leading politicians say is needed
uh it's certainly by virtue of being
Europe's economic uh Powerhouse and a
leading uh trade country uh Germany has
a special responsibility on these issues
and I think we have seen a lot of
progress have been made especially at
the European level when it comes to
addressing trade challenges especially
stemming from China there's been a lot
of progress in recent years on stepping
up uh for an investment screening export
control restrictions uh making uh the
the European procurement Market more
more safe from unfair competition and
addressing things like like illegal
subsidies so there has been progress on
that sort of trade defense area in
Germany are certainly been very
supportive of that where I think there
will need to be more work going forward
and Germany will play a key role is to
think about uh building new trade
relationships making sure that we don't
become protectionist or isolationists
but that we are investing in
diversifying trade relations and I think
that means doing more with countries
like Japan Australia Canada where we
still need to ratify a trade agreement
so here I think is for German to really
play a key role and I think actually one
of the question marks is where the USS
and the Biden Administration in its
trade agenda we saw recently the U.S
imposing these new uh restrictions on
tax credits for electric vehicles that
could have a bad impact for German car
companies I think in many ways it's not
Germany but it's actually the U.S it's a
question mark when it comes to global
trade Eric bradberg thank you
thank you very much